foreign
during one of these daily cancellation
segments last week we discussed the
violent nature of football and other
contact Sports a violent nature which
had come under intense scrutiny by the
media after as we talked about Bill's
Defender Demar Hamlin nearly died on the
field during a Sunday Night Football
matchup with the Cincinnati Bengals of
course as far as we know the Hamlin
incident may not have any had anything
to do with football violence still to
this point all we know is that he had a
cardiac emergency in the middle of the
game we have not been given any direct
evidence
that it was actually caused by a
collision on the field though it
certainly could have been either way
whatever the exact cause it remains an
extremely rare occurrence that anyone
has to be you know anyone has anyone has
to be taken off the field by an
ambulance and brought immediately to the
hospital that's rare it doesn't happen
very often
this in spite of the fact that football
is indeed a violent Sport and as I
argued during that segment it should
remain a violence point
now it's good to have these kinds of
physical even brutal full contact Sports
if for no other reason than the fact
that they serve as relatively healthy
relatively safe relatively productive
Outlets
for male aggression one of the great
services that sports like football
provide for societies that they give
young aggressive man men and boys a way
to harness and Channel all of that
energy this is one of the central
reasons why Sports exist to begin with
the violence is not the whole point but
it is part of the point and it's an
important part take it away and these
young men will find other outlets for
their aggression Outlets which you will
discover are not nearly so safe or
controlled as football that was my basic
point and it was a point that proved to
be very upsetting to people on the
internet especially after our marketing
team at Media Matters posted another of
their carefully cropped clips of my
monologue to Twitter
the full monologue which fleshes out my
point in rather precise detail went on
for I think 12 or 13 minutes but Jason
Campbell and Media Matters posted the 75
seconds which he felt was the most
likely to make the Pitchfork mob upset
especially when isolated from the full
context
and it seems that he made the right
choice because his clip garnered nearly
10 million views on Twitter and provoked
lots of angry reactions
before we continue I think it should be
it would be fair for me to you know go
back and we'll show the part of that
monologue that he posted and then we'll
talk about it here he is
let's consider football itself as a
sport
despite any rule changes or updates to
the equipment it is still a
fundamentally violent sport that's true
and and that's what it always will be
is that a bad thing no it's not
in fact it is a good and healthy thing
it is good that football is violent it
should stay violent it is good to have
violent Sports
okay we should have violent Sports if
anything we should have more of them
because a violent sport like football is
among other things
a relatively safe relatively safe and
relatively productive outlets for male
energy and aggression
okay there's a reason why many of the
media articles being written and
freaking out about football are being
written by women
because football is not no matter what
the NFL is trying to do football is not
for women there might be some women who
get into it but it's not really Four
Women it's not for you you don't
understand it you're not meant to
understand it this is actually a man's
thing
this is why violent games have existed
in every society going back to primitive
times they are a means of channeling and
harnessing male aggression
okay so I did say that football is a
man's sport
which uh you know why did I say that how
could I possibly justify such a
statement well because football was
invented by men and has been played
almost exclusively by men and the vast
majority of its fans are men and have
always been men and will always be men
that's why I said that does that mean
that no woman has ever watched football
or been a fan or been involved
professionally at some level no it just
means that football was made by men
and mostly four men this is a
statistical and historical reality it
isn't really up for debate okay if it
interferes with your girl power
fantasies that's your problem not mine I
don't really care
and apparently it did interfere with
lots of people's fantasies which is why
there were many tweets explaining why my
statements were terrible and wrong and
hurtful and sexist and so on
this continued this continued until the
scholars over at The Young Turks got
wind of the controversy and decided to
devote a lengthy segment responding to
and supposedly debunking my claims the
title of this segment on YouTube
declares that quote tyt demolishes
right-wing alpha male Matt Walsh for his
most recent sexist rants
this is nothing new I've been demolished
by many a left-wing YouTuber over the
years demolished at least according to
the titles they put on their videos
but as we've seen many times in the past
these demolitions usually end up being
rather uh anti-climactic if I must say
rarely do they live up to their own hype
perhaps though this young Turks video
will be different perhaps my demolition
will finally come to fruition
let's watch and find out
that is the infamous fascist misogynist
and other badist Matt Walsh
insisting that football is only for men
and we are about to prove him completely
wrong who could have seen that take
coming uh Jake did called it perfectly
just yesterday right here on tyt check
out this clip
so now it looks like the right wing is
trying to frame it like I I remember
when people were real men and they just
didn't mind people getting killed on the
field now the lips want to make this
soft so there isn't as many deaths on
the field
[Music]
thank God you're wearing a slightly
different colored shirt otherwise people
could have thought you did that live but
yeah no I I knew they were gonna
eventually celebrate the guy that the
fact they own the guy almost died right
and like oh it's supposed to be a lot of
sport man yeah and chicks wouldn't
understand nothing about it huh
my favorite thing about this dude is
that his dumb guy voice is
indistinguishable from his regular voice
he's doing an impression of an idiot and
yet sounds just like himself and
speaking of sounding like an idiot he
misses the point entirely of course if
if there is a right-wing take on the
Demar Hamlin injury it's that it's not
an injury
Jank is that how you pronounce I
honestly don't know how to pronounce his
name is trying to straw man us but he's
hilariously using the wrong straw man if
there was a conservative position on
this topic which there isn't okay
because it's not a political issue but
if there was it would be that Hamlin
collapsed for reasons wholly unrelated
to football the predominant view among
conservative pundits on the internet
from what I've seen is that I'm much
more plugged into that world than he is
is that this may have had something to
do with the vaccine
whether that's wrong or right like
that's when it comes to the Demar Hamlin
thing that's the thing that most
conservatives were talking about very
few are using this as an occasion to
defend violent Sports I am but I'm not
the official spokesman for conservative
pundits and none of us are as he says
celebrating the fact that the guy almost
died that's not happening anywhere so we
were promised a demolition and instead
so far we've gotten a series of
completely arbitrary and irrelevant
Straw Men that bear not even a passing
resemblance to any argument that anyone
has ever actually made not a great start
but uh let's continue
this video had two parts right so over
there really three parts one is not so
bad he's saying look it's a societally
acceptable way of uh releasing uh some
of the violent urges uh that people of
society and men in particular have
that's not that wrong right but when
they celebrate the second part is
celebrating like oh violence is a good
thing yeah oh yeah it's great
no but wait it doesn't have to be this
violent they talked about a little bit
yesterday I'll just tell you real quick
between 1900 and 1905 45 different
people died on the football field
because it used to be even more violent
they would literally kill each other on
the field and guess what happened the
government stepped in it was Teddy
Roosevelt when he was president and said
I'm not going to let you kill each other
on the field like this this is insane
you have to make it less violent and you
know what happened after that it became
way more popular because people didn't
want to go see a sport and have people
murder each other on the field and so it
doesn't mean it's going to be less
popular doesn't mean it's going to be a
less of a sport or anything along those
lines if you don't celebrate people like
Demar Hamlin almost dying on the field
oh okay I get it so so this is I see
what's happening here this is the exact
opposite of a demolition actually he
agrees with my argument but is trying to
find a way to disagree with it he
concedes my point about football being a
healthy outlet for male aggression that
was essentially my entire point so if he
will admit that I'm right or his words
not that wrong then there's not much
else to talk about but he keeps talking
anyway even after having long since run
out of anything relevant to say as is is
custom he observes that um
football used to be a lot more violent
than it is today if that sounds familiar
it's probably because I made the exact
same point in the very monologue he is
attempting to rebut
that's what I said
it's the left-wing media that tried to
turn Damar Hamlin into a conversation
about football's increasing violence
remember a White House reporter told
asked the president about the you know
his football becoming too dangerous
as I said in that segment football is
actually becoming much less dangerous if
there was a time to have a national
dialogue about the violence in football
it was 50 years ago or a hundred years
ago
today it's about as non-violent as it
can possibly be while still remaining
something resembling the sport as it was
originally designed the Hamlin injury if
it was a football injury was the result
of a routine football play that was by
no means especially violent or brutal
there would be no way to take that play
out of the game without turning it into
a two-hand touch or flag football
which is why once again it makes no
sense to use the mar Hamlin as a jumping
off point for a discussion about the
violence of the sport it has nothing to
do with the violence of the sport
it would say it was a basic normal
tackle
that's all it was
it was a not especially violent play in
a sport that has become less and less
violently with each passing year that
was my point the point that Jank
restates while pretending to rebut
but now it's time for the woman on the
panel to chime in and she's the one okay
this is where they're setting her up
okay they're teeing her off and uh but
this is where the real demolition is
going to happen she's gonna set me
straight let's listen
okay so his the Crux of his argument is
women shouldn't have a say because men
are the ones that have violent urges and
you chicks don't get it your chicks
don't get the violent urges that we have
that we need to get out which I almost
can see like I'm a CIS woman and I am
raising apparently so far as I know a
CIS baby I've been raising a CIS son for
two years and there are like yeah I
totally get that there are like male
things that are ingrained in him
I wouldn't I would actually almost
accept that argument from this Tool Shed
if I knew that he had no opinions on
abortion female reproductive rights uh
the price of tampons you know maternity
leave if he shut his stupid bearded pie
hole about any of those things that he
literally as a man does not understand
about being a woman then I might accept
his argument but I know this
bearded
douche nozzle has so much to say about
women that he knows nothing about so for
him to turn around be like women I don't
even want to hear from you because you
guys just don't shut up shut your stupid
dumb pie hole you dime stored
Justin Thoreau
lady listen if you want to be included
in the football conversation you're not
helping your case here you're so
emotional you can barely see straight
calm down cupcake take a breath you're
being hysterical
okay can you imagine trying to watch a
game and this woman comes running in
you're trying to watch the game let me
tell you about my CIS baby
my God shut up
now as to your points if anything in
that rambling stuttering pile of words
can be described as a point I would say
this
first of all I do not now have nor have
I ever had an opinion about the price of
tampons
I don't even know how much they cost I
couldn't tell you
is it is it three dollars a tampon I
don't know 30 cents
I do have an opinion about abortion and
other reproductive quote unquote
reproductive issues because as a man I
am 50 involved in reproduction
it is as much my issue as it is yours
I was also once an unborn baby
so if you want reproduction to be a
woman's issue you need to figure out a
way to reproduce entirely without the
involvement of a male member of the
species until you do that
this is our issue as much as it is yours
so you got to deal with that actually
let me clarify that you have to figure
out a way to reproduce without a male
member of the species and also to
reproduce yourself
because if you're reproducing and making
another person
then already it's not just your issue
because there's another person involved
so no matter what in reproduction there
are other people involved it's not just
you
second to clarify
I don't disregard your opinion about
football
I don't
I disregard your opinion about
everything
including football
not because you're a woman but because
you use the phrase CIS baby
that automatically I want you to
understand this that automatically
invalidates everything you will ever say
about anything ever
not that on this topic you actually have
much to say in the first place you've
yet to approach anything that might be
called an argument but but still
everything's out the window now
because you talked about your CIS baby
but anyway you know what I will listen
for another minute to give you one last
chance to put together some kind of
argument let's go
he's just saying women what
are not intelligent enough to understand
football what do you mean they can't
understand yeah there's it's not that
complicated there's literally posted
rules like you can Google the rules of
football and anyone with like basic
level of intelligence cannot there's
literally a list of rules and go okay I
understand if you watch you read the
rules you watch one game and go I get it
I get it it's not magic it's not magic
you know it's not like do are men not
allowed to watch
gymnastics or baking or like this is the
most sexist going both ways sexist
argument from the dumbest douche nozzle
okay this is what tells me that not only
are you unable to understand football
but apparently you also don't understand
English
I didn't say that women can't comprehend
the rules of football I mean you
probably can't which is why you're
sitting there Googling it
what I said quite clearly from the
context is that women generally don't
understand don't relate to the desire to
watch much less participate in violence
as entertainment
males understand violence as
entertainment in a way that women don't
just like my wife understands the appeal
of Gilmore Girl reruns in a way that I
don't
the urge to seek outlets for that sort
of physical aggression is something that
males experience and relate to much more
than females there are exceptions
but the exceptions are exceptions that's
why we call them exceptions
is that clear enough for you or are you
still confused do I need to speak slower
in conclusion the Young Turk Squad here
has spent 10 minutes trying to find a
reason to disagree with my point but
sadly they never found one
all we've really learned here is that
they have trouble comprehending simple
English sentences we've also learned
that the woman at the table has a baby
who we should all be praying for and
we've learned that all three of them at
the table are today canceled that'll do
it for this portion of the shows and
move over to the members block you can
become a member and watch the members
block by using Code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
hope see over there if not talk to you
tomorrow God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you